hey everyone divolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over
i guess my thoughts on tokyo revenges
and why i think it's an amazing series
that everyone needs to pick up and read
or at the very minimum watch the anime
as it's doing a wonderful job with the
adaptation
but before we get into all of that if
you guys are new around here and want to
keep up to date with the latest tokyo
revenges
reviews spoilers and more then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and also
be sure to leave a like on the video as
well as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people
but enough of that let's get into this
amazing series so
i think i'm in love with tokyo revenges
like call me a hype man or what you will
as i don't really dabble into too many
different anime
as basic as it is i'm a shonen stan but
i know it and unless i get that public
admission that the anime itself is great
i don't often tend to even bother
reading the synopsis and i think that a
lot of you are probably extremely
similar
like if i'm being honest again i dropped
demon slayer initially because of how
annoying zenitsu was
and then only came back after the
nuclear blast explosion of exposure that
episode 19 was given on twitter and
hardly ever
do i decide to pick up a manga like i've
only ever read a few manga all the way
through
or well at the moment at least until i
decided to watch the tokyo avengers
anime
and for the first time i was so
enthralled and at awe with an amazing
concept that i decided to pick up the
manga before the third episode of the
anime had even released
and now i'm currently caught up in one
of the most amazing heart-wrenching
and literally cry-worthy arcs so far
especially
with this new huge revelation that has
happened between mikey and sakamichi but
let's not get into all of that as i
don't want to spoil anything if possible
i just want to give my thoughts on why i
think this is truly an amazing series in
general and why i think you should read
it the series starts off with a 26 year
old takamichi who doesn't seem very
confident in life and often thinks back
on his past mistakes
one night while at the subway and close
to the platform drop-off
takamichi is pushed by an unknown
assailant unknown to him at the time
this would spark the start of what i
imagine his life-altering ability
takamichi has been granted the ability
to travel exactly 12
years to the day back in time by luck or
by something else
this is the first time travel anime or
manga that i've watched or at least
at the time of writing this i think it
is i know i haven't seen steins gate or
any other time-based animes but i've
heard that tokyo revenge's concept
is like another show called erased but
still i would like to think that tokyo
avengers has its own kind of feel
like the main character to me just feels
so real i think it's because of his
constant will
to never give up and always trying his
best to i guess
look on the bright side of every
scenario or situation he falls into
especially with being given the second
chance to save his lost dead ex
and best friend drakken then more
recently akun and other kitamin members
i think akun puts it beautifully in
episode 4 and gives us a very
straightforward foreshadowing of who
takamichi truly is
when he calls takamichi our crybaby hero
as
every time takamichi stands up for his
friends or people
in need his face is filled with tears
and emotion flows with a wave of
ferocity that shunts the soul of the
person
intended with his outcry although
takamichi can't necessarily fight or
isn't someone like mikey who can
dispatch an opponent with a single kirk
the fights that he is a part of are the
most enthralling and exciting parts of
the entire show
as i'm constantly stuck in the same
boots as takamichi
extremely frightened and not really
knowing what to do while bodies get
thrown around
all over the place and it's even more
rewarding when you have takamichi come
out on top not due to skill or strength
but due to the fact that his back
is bigger than anyone else's while
fighting and everyone is willing to
follow him to the ultimate demise if it
means possibly saving a friend
or winning a battle technically i've
been uploading on and off on youtube for
seven years now and surprisingly in
these last few months that i've
restarted content on my channel
mainly the anime kind i've noticed the
insanely quick rise to number one in the
oricon anime ranking displacing manga
like jujutsu kaizen attack on titan
black clover
marshall and my hero academia to just
name a few
i think before the anime started which
was a few months ago the total copies in
circulation was only around 8.5 to 9
million
which is still a lot but now it's
heading straight for the my hero
academia community
selling over three million copies in the
last two weeks alone
with the way it's currently going and
the moments that are bound to happen i
can see it hitting some insane
exponential growth maybe in a similar
way to jiu-jitsu kaizen
or demon slayer which the letter is
still selling around an average of
300 000 copies per week if not more on
occasion which is insane
due to the fact the anime has actually
been stopped for over a year now
this video was more or less just my
thoughts and a discussion of this series
without spoiling anything for you lovely
anime onlys
the show truly hits me in the monkey
brain spot with the hands that get
thrown and then it stabs me in the heart
every
time we lose an amazing character and
then it gets me again when he saves them
the emotion truly flows goosebumps
surely do pop up
and this smile on my face is at its
largest every time i see a new chapter
or episode release
lastly i wanted to bring up so that
people don't assume that japan is doing
some hitler sympathizing
or trying to brainwash the youth is that
the gang toeman or the tokyo majin gang
symbol
is a swastika and in no way is their
symbol related to the nazi regime
naturally in our world hitler and the
nazi party decided to take a buddhist
symbol of peace and use it in the most
horrific manner possible
absolutely going against all of the
morals or code that it stands for
hence the saying on how he took the
symbol and twisted it as he did this
with the meaning
and the symbol itself literally this
isn't the case with tokyo revenges as
with tomin it is a symbol that
represents good luck and prosperity
which is something that both mikey and
takamichi stand for
as takamichi is constantly fighting for
the prosperity and
longevity of the members of tomen along
with hina
in chinese culture the symbol is called
the wanzai which means the all things
symbol and in japanese it is pronounced
manji hence the gang's name the tokyo
manji gang
but anyway i hope you've enjoyed my
thoughts on tokyo revenges and why i can
definitely see it becoming another huge
shonen
maybe even the next big thing maybe it
already is
also if you are new around here and want
to keep up to date with the latest tokyo
revenges reviews spoilers and more
videos like this
then be sure to hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as it really helps out with
the algorithm and pushes my stuff to a
bunch of new amazing people
but enough of that for now it's been
your professional degenerate diavolo
and i'll see you all in a bit bye
you